so back in 2013 when i first started
this channel god i can't believe it's
been that long
it's been almost 10 years uh one of the
first videos that we did was
electro explained but it was nine
minutes long it was a static image and
it was not very in-depth and because
jamie foxx's electro was going to appear
or at least slate it to appear in
spider-man no way home i figured we
would
make a video explaining the character
give you an in-depth explanation so you
guys can walk away as an expert on who
max dillon
is so max dylan or electro first
appeared in amazing spider-man number
nine in 1964 and was created by stan lee
and steve ditko but here's the funny
thing
as with most marvel comic characters
while you did get something of an origin
for elektro in his early appearance you
actually got a far more in-depth origin
and amazing spider-man issue number 422
by tom defalco now with this origin
being more comprehensive it did bookend
to the original origin from spider-man
number 9 and 64.
but this one offers a lot more insight
into the life and times of maxwell dylan
and why it is he ended up becoming the
person that he was so what this really
told us
was that at a previous point in time his
father
was exceedingly abusive towards his
mother now it wasn't really on the same
level
as like brian banner in the sense that
uh bruce banner's father was abusive
towards bruce
and his mother but the father of electro
was really just beating on its mother
now eventually he abandoned the family
and in a lot of ways it left a kind of
survivor's guilt so to speak with
regards to his mother
insofar as she saw herself as a failure
because she couldn't keep her husband at
the same time
she was also exceedingly protective of
maxwell dylan to the point where she
actually kind of kept him from really
being able to get out there and
experience the world where he could get
bumps bruises make mistakes screw things
up and basically struggle in the world
to understand that resolve is what's
needed to make it in the world and so
because of that as he grew older and
even to the point where he actually
considered college his mom always shot
him down and said no you're not ready
for that kind of environment out there
right you don't have the intellect you
don't have the
the attributes necessary to make it in
the world and was always doing what she
could
to keep him close to home now again a
lot of that seemed to be a psychological
extension of the fact that she had lost
her husband right her husband had walked
away
and in an effort to continue or at least
to to prevent herself from
experiencing that kind of loss again
despite how twisted that whole situation
was she was always trying to keep her
son
close to the vest now eventually she
ended up dying about three days before
his 25th birthday and then it turned out
at least from his perspective
she was essentially right that when he
went out into the world the first thing
he did was latch on to a person he
immediately latched on to a girl named
norma lynn and the two of them were
married
really six months after they'd met now
the environment was really conducive to
this circumstance right they both worked
for the same electrical company there
was already chemistry there but it was
one of these things where she ultimately
left him because from her perspective
he had no real drive or ambition right
that he was an electrical lineman
and had no desire to move beyond this
station and that because of that she
ultimately saw him as somebody with no
ambition that would no drive to improve
himself which really seemed to kind of
indicate there would really be no drive
to
improve the relationship beyond its
current standard until she ultimately
left
the result of this is that the constant
loss and the fact that he had kind of
been
left ill-equipped to function in the
world really turned maxwell dylan into a
very harsh person
so much so that he wouldn't help anybody
unless there was something to be gained
in it right he basically went
from one end to the other and that makes
sense when the pendulum swings it swings
in the extremes right it goes from one
end to the other
all this came to a head when he was
looking to essentially gain a promotion
and instead of just kind of working his
butt off the way that we normally expect
and so far as
you know equal treatment from our
employers and being allowed to move up
based on our performance on the job
that instead when there was a lineman
that was stuck ultimately maxwell
dylan's response was i'm not going to
help him unless you
basically offer me a promotion give me
more money whatever the case is now
during this time
lightning ended up striking really in
the midst of his storms it struck this
pole
killed the lineman who was stuck and
because of his proximity to some
electrical wires
dylan was shocked as well but instead of
killing him it turned him into electro
and so given the harsh direction his
life had gone in he did the most logical
thing which was to become a villain
to use this this newfound power for the
purpose of just kind of
achieving his own personal goals right
now this of course again kind of
wrapping back around to amazing
spider-man number nine
brought him in direct conflict with
peter parker and one of the funny things
about this
is that right off the bat within the
first two years of elektro's appearance
in marvel comics he was starkly
different from a lot of other villains
that we'd seen
first and foremost the power he
possessed was not really brought to us
in the full-scale form that it would be
and in fact there were future upgrades
that took place with regards to his
power that helped to boost it but the
main focus here is that with him being a
villain of spider-man
the idea was to basically show what
spider-man was capable of that the
ability of peter parker to be a
superhero was not relegated to web
slinging and punching but also using his
intellect as well it was one of the
hallmarks of stan lee's storytelling
back in the day
that his desire was to convey to the
reader there's more to being a superhero
than just beating people up
having intelligence being able to use
your brain as much as your brawn
is a hallmark of what it means to truly
be an effective hero and so the funny
thing about this
is that there were kind of plot threads
that were thrown in there for the
purpose of adding a little bit of drama
that where peter parker ultimately
defeated electro using a combination of
rubber gloves and shoes right just due
to their resistance to uh to electricity
then it basically also led to j jonah
jameson in this exact same story in the
beginning when elektra went into a bank
and robbed it basically coming to the
realization and really just kind of
convincing himself
that peter parker and electro were the
same person and so this was really more
stan lee and steve ditko writing the
narrative in such a way to where
peter parker just couldn't catch a break
that j jonah jameson
always had it out for peter and he would
cook the books however he needed to
to ensure that it looked like peter
parker was the villain right the daily
bugle would always kind of be this
public enemy of peter
and so far as how they wrote their
articles and how they depicted him and
the press
but beyond that despite elektro being
defeated again he had a huge involvement
in terms of how villains were portrayed
in marvel comics the reason why was
because
villains were pretty straightforward
back then right i mean at this point in
time
the the marvel landscape was still being
fleshed out in a lot of ways right back
in 1964 1965
marvel was still figuring some things
out but by and large villains were not
really the main focus a lot of it was on
heroes right evolving heroes growing
heroes that's why more often than not
when you looked at teams like the x-men
or you look at the introduction of the
inhumans or black panther that they had
a lot of crossover
with stories belonging to the fantastic
four fantastic four was marvel's premier
superhero team they were the most
popular comic that marvel had running at
the time
right up until the releases of
spider-man then that one took over in
popularity and so you saw a lot of
superheroes being brought in and being
you know
really premiering in fantastic four
stories but more so than that
superheroes were really just being
shared around right you had heroes who
were appearing in other hero stories
heroes whose motivations and their
immoral compass was being solidified
over and over and over again and while i
wouldn't say
that villains were taking the back seat
and being left behind i will say they
weren't necessarily the main focus
elektro changed that because almost
immediately after his appearance
stan lee and bill everett threw him into
the pages of daredevil issue number two
where he fought matt murdock for the
very first time and actually held his
own to a degree right following that you
go into amazing spider-man annual number
one in 1964
which basically gave us the sinister six
and this was a genius idea on behalf of
marvel right as most of you guys know
the sinister six was a
concept created by marvel to basically
unify the various villains right and in
a lot of ways
it was i wouldn't say designed to be the
antithesis of the fantastic four
but it was designed to build on the
popularity of a superhero team but super
villains instead
and it was composed of spider-man's
really top-tier villains at the time
really his only villains at the time but
basically having this team working
together for the purpose of defeating
spider-man
was huge right because it basically hit
all the marks you focus on the
intelligence of doctor octopus and
organizing the team
you focus on the power of electro
insofar as what happens when peter
parker fights him on his home turf
literally
in an electrical plant right all these
different characters mysterio so on and
so forth sandman
all these guys are really kind of
elevated and beefed up and not only did
it help to basically solidify spider-man
as a hero that could essentially
overcome the odds despite the sheer
amount of resistance he's facing but it
also helped to kind of set the stage for
what the various villains could become
and so following that you go into
daredevil annual in 1967
and then you move elektro beyond simply
being a spider-man villain and you
actually started moving him in the
direction of becoming what was an effect
of villain for hire the reason for this
was that at the time
while you had like the frightful four
that basically faced off against the the
fantastic four you had the sinister six
facing off against spider-man you had
what is in a lot of ways a much lesser
known team
called the emissaries of evil that faced
off against daredevil and electro was
brought on to become part of the
emissaries of evil to kind of expand
this notion that he was a villain
that really covered a lot of the the
capabilities that were necessary
to face off against a lot of different
superheroes and so again it was kind of
big because following that
going into fantastic four annual number
three you ended up having electro who
actually face off against the fantastic
four
at the behest of doctor doom so again
kind of expanding this roster now one of
the funny things about this comic is it
really stands out this particular story
stands out in comparison to most all the
other stories
because you did experience a team up
between spider-man and the fantastic
four
much later on in peter parker's
spectacular spider-man number 42
when elektro joined the frightful four
and then fought both spider-man
and the fantastic four and held his own
right and that was one of the stories
where it just kind of solidified this
guy's huge right this guy's a very big
deal being able to hold his own and in
fact
actually stand toe to toe with the human
torch johnny storm as well as the thing
ben grimm and spider-man along with the
rest of the fantastic four was massive
and in fact a lot of the stories that
would come much much later stories like
the raft
things like that that basically had
electro facing off against the this
veritable
you know who's who of the superhero
community all has its roots in this
fantastic four
and peter parker the spectacular
spider-man story face off against a
fantastic four and was able to hold his
own now following that
you actually go into one of the more
lesser known stories written by steve
gerber in 1975
and 1976 which was called omega the
unknown now omega the unknown was
marvel's attempt to really one of their
last attempts to basically take a comic
book character
created and just throw it out into solo
series and see what works
at that point in time marvel had largely
been focusing on things like marvel
premiere
marvel 21 different things like that to
kind of give us these these stories that
took place in comics like marvel
spotlight to basically give us
characters and teams
that they didn't want to invest the time
in as far as like a solo book went
if it didn't succeed uh omega the
unknown was one of the last holdouts
right one of the last times that marvel
did that of course
it was a terribly received comic it was
cancelled after like 10 or 12 issues due
to low sales
but one of the things that happens in
the story is because of electro's
popularity at the time
marvel threw him in there hoping that
elektra would help to kind of beef up
the story a little bit
and give it a strong start and so in
issues number two and three you actually
see elektro fight the incredible hulk
and take him out in one punch
it was huge right just one hit and he
takes out the hulk that was
big right at that point in time that was
massive the comic alone already had a
pretty strong roster right the
incredible hulk electro omega whose
powers were a little ambiguous along
with his name
it was a terrible concept for a comic
book but seeing a character like elektro
take out the incredible hulk just in one
single shot was
again one of these things that kind of
established him as being a solid
character now one of the big
issues this comic had and people even
still talk about it to this day
is the inconsistency and power that if
elektra was a villain who could be
defeated by a superhero like spider-man
and spider-man had previously been
defeated by the incredible hulk how much
sense did it make
that electro could defeat the incredible
hulk right especially if it's just done
in one single shot but that's one of the
things that marvel kind of chalked up
and even in the pages right they called
them the omega letters
and the pages themselves marvel kind of
responded to this by simply saying well
you can't look at comics as an absolute
right just because the circumstance
happened in one comic does not mean it's
guaranteed to happen across every single
comic right but regardless of how you
slice it in the aftermath of this and
really for the next 20 years or so
electro was a character that had the
potential
to be massive in terms of his danger to
the overall superhero community but
there didn't really seem to be a lot of
emphasis put
on him now as to why that's the case i
don't fully know
i would argue that a lot of that's
because by the time you got to the late
1970s going into the early 1980s
marvel wanted to focus more on cerebral
stories involving the failure of
superheroes
a lot of that really seemed to come out
of the death of gwen stacy
and really even the dark knight returns
right just coming out of stories you
know where where
you had like batman who was darker face
off against superman right kind of
ushering in the bronze age of comics as
we know it but focusing on
more character-driven stories that
belong to superheroes that show that
superheroes could fail
the rise of the anti-hero different
things along those lines electro was
again very much
a villain for hire and so because of
that there really didn't seem to be a
lot of impetus a lot of focus put on his
character
and so following that one of the big
things that really came out of this era
it goes into the 1990s and the 1990s
again kind of continued this idea
and you did see efforts by marvel
especially with tom lyle in uh
spider-man unlimited number nine
in 1995 that were designed to actually
beef up electro
and make him a more significant
character specifically when he joins
mysterio sinister seven now the sinister
seven
is looked at as you know from spider-man
fans as i understand it with
kind of didn't really happen and the
reason why was because the sinister
seven was largely rooted in the clone
saga right this idea
of kane and and ben reilly the idea like
which one is actually peter parker um
the whole point of the sinister seven as
it was assembled was designed to be
a version of the sinister six that
focused and was designed to belong to
kane as opposed to the traditional
peter parker spider-man sinister six for
its part the story was interesting but
at the end of the day because clone saga
was so reviled
among spider-man fans a lot of times it
seems to be kind of lumped in with it
and so because clone song is considered
bad
that sinister 7 is considered bad as
well i'm not entirely sure i agree with
that there were elements of it that i
thought were cool
but that was kind of the running thing
when it came to electro right as a
villain for hire it was always
if you have the money to hire electro
he'll do almost anything you want in
terms of taking down various villains or
facing off against various threats which
again
was designed to kind of go into this
idea that he was a credible threat when
you look at captain america issues 411
through 413 by mark gruenwald which was
actually written back in 1993
it's electro facing off against captain
america and a handful of the avengers
and again holding his own against these
guys now one of the other cool things
that happened here was that uh kind of
circling back to amazing spider-man 422
that electro had experienced a big boost
to his powers and the reason why was
because up to that point
electro despite being a guy who was a
kind of a harbinger or a source of
electricity at the end of the day was
like a battery if anything else right he
needed to maintain a charge
the boost in power that he received that
was really due to a guy named rose which
we don't necessarily need to go into
jack's character but the boost in power
that he received
actually was the results of marvel
transforming him and really moving him
away from it being this kind of
battery-esque character and turning him
into what was in effect
living lightning so he didn't really
need a charge anymore
not only that one of the things that was
kind of interesting was that in the
early days again kind of
focusing on his character and in terms
of expanding him around marvel had
considered throwing him
on the brotherhood of evil mutants this
was done by way of magneto approaching
elektro and actually asking him to join
the team
ultimately this didn't really happen
because magneto didn't consider electro
to be a mutant but at the end of the day
saw the potential of his power in the
aftermath of this with regards to
amazing spider-man 422
he also had the ability to tap into the
electromagnetic spectrum which again
seemed to focus on the fact that magneto
saw that electro could become
a wildly powerful being right a
non-mutant equivalent to an omega level
character
and so because of that electro was one
of these guys were again kind of
beefed up routinely in marvel but not a
whole lot was done with regards to
giving us this full
on total display of the kinds of things
electro could do now a lot of this
really came to a head when you got to
the early to mid 2000s and the launch of
the new avengers now to kind of
sidetrack here for a second we're not
going to go super in depth into why this
happened we've done this before
but with regards to to the launch of the
new avengers because i i treat every
video like somebody's first video
the new avengers was the desire by
marvel to basically rework the avengers
team and the reason for this is that
while you might look at that and say
why didn't they just change the roster
the truth was this has happened a
million times before right you had the
original avengers team
the roster changed relatively frequently
and actually got pretty massive in size
this led to the splitting of the
avengers insofar as you had avengers
west coast and then you had avengers
east coast which was basically the main
avengers team
you had other stories and other other
events that kind of focused on that but
at the end of the day
marvel didn't want to do what they'd
done before marvel wanted to completely
shift things up and so basically
disbanding the avengers in the avengers
disassembled story
and then relaunching it and reforming
the team as a new avengers which even in
the confines of the story itself was
designed to kind of correct the end team
mistakes they experienced
basically led to a whole new avengers
roster right captain america wolverine
iron man spider-man so on and so forth
the first real story that you saw with
the new avengers was called
breakout and this of course written by
brian michael bendis brought in the
character of elektro by this point in
time bendis had basically built on the
existing power boost electro had
and he was contracted by elektra who was
secretly a scroll at the time kind of
setting the stage for secret invasion to
basically take down the raft or take
down power to the raft to free
all the different villains who were
there to operate as a kind of
distraction while the scrolls continue
their campaign
of replacing villains replacing heroes
and just normal humans with scroll
replicants and the heroes being totally
unaware that it's happening
elektro of course did exactly that but
it was a massive display of power it was
huge when it happened now we had seen
things happen like that before to a
degree elektro trying to destroy the
world on several occasions and coming
relatively close to it with the combined
efforts of the avengers the fantastic
four and spider-man having to take him
out it's one of these things where it
was been just kind of building on a lot
of the stuff that we've seen with his
character over the years
but again following that you didn't
really see a whole lot with his
character a whole lot being done by
marvel with regards to kind of
displaying the fact that elektro was
every bit the credible threat that we
knew he was however
a lot of this really changed during the
run of dan slot and this is one of the
reasons why i say dance slot spider-man
run is probably one of the greatest runs
that i've ever been written about the
character and a lot of people don't
really like it right a lot of
traditional spider-man fans don't really
like it um i kind of consider them
hipsters right they're like spider-man
was better in the 1980s i don't think he
was
i love dan slot's run especially
superior spider-man but one of the funny
things about this
is that you had a story called ends of
the earth right and this really took
place in spider-man 682 through 683 and
if we're being honest with ourselves was
already a part of dance slot spider-man
run but one of the things that had
happened here
is that you actually had elektro face
off against thor which was cool right it
was something that we hadn't really seen
before now again of course
elektra was ultimately defeated but this
went into the superior spider-man run
and specifically this was avenging
spider-man issues 18-19 and then you
also saw a lot of involvement in
superior spider-man team-up issues 5-7
one of the things to kind of specify
here
is that during the superior spider-man
run because in a lot of ways it was kind
of landmark we'd never really seen an
instance where somebody had taken over
the body of peter parker and replaced
him for any real measure of time the
closest you got was the clone saga
um that you actually saw marvel spitting
out a bunch of different superior
spider-man
uh stories right superior foes of
spider-man uh avenging spider-man
superior spider-man team up there were
some pretty cool stories that went on
there but one of the things that took
place here is you actually saw elektro
essentially returning
and then facing off against superior
spider-man only to be defeated
eventually this led to him basically
escaping alongside the other five
members of what we're called the
superior six as opposed to the sinister
six and then in turn again you know more
or less being defeated
by uh by spider-man but it was one of
these things where routinely he would
kind of pop up and dance slots run
really seemed to focus on elevating
electro now
one of the things that happened here in
2015 it came with mike costa and you
actually saw something that was
introduced called the electro verse but
what was done
here is that the idea of electroverse
was designed to introduce this notion
of electro having something that was a
compliment or something that kind of
existed in the same capacity as like the
council of kings and the since you had
like a council of electros it was
short-lived not a whole lot came out of
it but it was still a cool concept it
was still a cool idea so again
a few efforts being made here and there
by marvel to kind of beef the character
up
but whether it's because of the fact
that the efforts simply weren't enough
the stories weren't significant enough
or there was just wasn't a whole lot of
interest in the character
there really didn't seem to be a lot
going on with the character of elektro
and so what you ended up getting was
basically the demise of his character
and amazing spider-man vol
4. again kind of coming towards the tail
end of danslot's run when you actually
had a character named francine frye who
had come up on the scene now
francine frye had actually been around
since 2014 and she was somebody who had
accidentally been killed by electro
and it was one of the aspects of
danslot's run focusing on the mental
state of maxwell dillon the
idea of remorse regret the fact that he
felt bad for having killed her
accidentally but during the whole idea
of the jackal the the clone conspiracy
event that francine fry was brought in
as an effort to try to convince maxwell
dylan to undergo a procedure with
regards to his
powers ultimately the process ended up
leading to francine fry
absorbing the power of maxwell dylan
maxwell dying in the process
and francine becoming the new electro
the response to this was pretty divisive
this took place during that era of
marvel comics when you had people who
had kind of claimed to have read marvel
comics for a long long time but couldn't
really answer any rudimentary questions
about them
and so it's one of these things where
people seem to get bent out of shape
over the fact that electro had quote
unquote been killed now anybody who
reads comics for any real measure of
time
will tell you there's no sense in
complaining over character changes
because they all go back to the status
quo in the end right everything goes
back to normal that captain america was
a hydra agent
until he wasn't until he went back to
being captain america again right that
sam wilson was captain america
until he went back to being falcon that
everything always usually goes back to
the status quo
very rarely does that not happen and so
the results of this really came to
fruition
with uh amazing spider-man vol 5 issue
number 69 now that's currently
part of the ongoing run that's written
by nick spencer right nick spencer
basically took over spider-man
following the end of dan's slots run
specifically during the chameleon
conspiracy event so it actually happened
uh earlier this year but essentially
electro's been brought back right that
maxwell dylan has returned
and ultimately his powers are back as
well so elektro it's back to being
himself now
i imagine this is being done because of
the fact that electro is going to appear
in spiderman no way home that's
basically why you're seeing him return
but regardless of the reason it would
have happened anyway so those of you
guys who are new to comics just keep in
mind that when they change characters
don't get bent out of shape right i've
been reading for 25 years very rarely
has there ever been an instance where a
character has been changed and not gone
back to the status quo right it's just
one of those things where everything
just kind of switches around and
everything gets changed if for no other
reason to shuffle up things so they
don't they don't become mundane and then
everything goes back to being normal
right jane foster with thor
odin's son is thor again so don't don't
get caught up in the politics of it all
right and don't let the internet talk
you into being mad about it right just
take it for what it is to you know enjoy
the ride and then just let things go
back to normal when they do so with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an
end uh thank you guys for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace